c'est ben a menacé des bananes qui était
censé de jeter ce qui devrait aller à la
poubelle pour certains deviez de la
matière première pour ses bourdes ça
c'est la drêche donc c'est ce qu'on
récupère les microbrasseries le grain
qui va se retrouver dans les biscuits
[Musique]
l'entreprise est en forte croissance
depuis le lancement de ses premiers
biscuits à la fin 2018 double très peu
donc on est en train de regarder
justement là à voir des nouveaux locaux
présentement parce que notre capacité
est rendu au maximum la pme produits
8010 cuit par jour ils sont offerts dans
une cinquantaine de points de vente et
surtout en ligne où se réalise environ
70% des ventes notamment par l'entremise
des fermes lufa et de cook it
les gens nous contactent en fait pour
pour faire partie pour être un
partenaire pour distribuer ses c'est
bien c'est le fun de voir que les
mentalités changent
l'équipe compte maintenant sept
personnes avec ces deux nouvelles
employées bien heureuse de se joindre à
l'aventuré
je pense que c'est super c'est dans
l'air du temps et on devrait tous agir
de cette manière là quand je regardais
mes offres d'emploi effectivement gens
regardaient au niveau des valeurs qui
sont défendues par les entreprises on
retrouve la peugeot betteraves dans nos
biscuits avec l'adresse ici même même
chose pour nous
lors de sa première année de production
en 2019 style goda récupérer 20 tonnes
de drêches de pulpe et de fruits le
volume a doublé l'an dernier et
l'objectif et 2 300 tonnes cette année
et quatre fois plus l'an prochain ce
sera développement ça devrait sortir
sous peu l'entreprise travaille sur de
nouveaux biscuits no 6 sur des produits
de boulangerie en collaboration avec les
3 brasseurs on prend leur drêche humide
qui provient de leur brasse 1 on a
développé un modèle nous pour être
capable de transformer ça en poudre qui
est très nutritive donc qui très élevé
en protéines très élevée en fibres et en
soutien partenaires et qui est fait avec
la leurs fournisseurs
le pain est ce pain là qui va se
retrouver sur leur menu dans l'est dans
les prochains mois en plus de réduire le
gaspillage l'entreprise tend vers le
zéro déchet ou produits sont offerts en
vrac chez certains détaillants et selon
ben ali le son avec des sacs
compostables des boîtes en carton
recyclé et de l'anc le végétal
l'objectif des stéroïdes c'est vraiment
d'être le leader en termes d'économie
circulaire non plus qu'on roule c'était
un exemple pour d'autres entreprises
la pme espère aussi implanter son modèle
dans d'autres villes au cours des
prochaines années estime eric lhomeau
radio-canada mourir